[Music]
on this Sunday night the clock is
ticking for hostages and gazin after 50
days in Hamas
captivity 17 more hostages are released
and now the US president's push to
extend the ceasefire that's my goal
that's our goal and the race to provide
Aid during a pause that's being called
too little and for many too late mass
shooting in Winnipeg we're dealing with
something very very serious today today
the overnight violence that's left three
dead and two critically injured and
federal clean energy regulations not in
Alberta invoking the sovereignty act may
be political theater but other provinces
are
watching global national with foreign
Asser reporting tonight Colleen
Christie Freedom after 50 days in
captivity today Hamas handed over 17
more hos hostages on the third day of a
high stakes humanitarian pause nine
children were among the group of 14
Israelis and three foreign Nationals
released to the Red Cross including dual
American Israeli citizen Abigail Adan
who turned four on
Friday and in the West Bank Jubilation
as 39 Palestinian detainees were
released from Israeli prisons following
that third hostage Exchange
good evening thanks for joining us there
were no delays today as both sides stuck
to the terms of the deal and tonight
there's hope the humanitarian pause may
be extended after reports Hamas is
seeking to push the pause beyond the
initial 4 days and that could be crucial
in securing the release of the only
Canadian believed to be held captive by
Hamas Judy Weinstein who was not on the
list of hostages released today Redmond
Shannon has our top story tonight
Hamas video showing a relatively Smooth
release of 17 hostages on Sunday day
three of what is set to be a 4-day truce
at least for
now cheering crowds welcomed some of the
14 Israeli hostages home the three non-
Israelis are Thai
citizens similar scenes of joy in the
West Bank as Israel releases 39 more
Palestinian prisoners in
return newly freed Omar alatan says he
wants to see all Palestinian prisoners
freed from Israeli jails among Sunday's
released hostages is the broet family
mom Hagar and her kids 10-year-old ofri
Yuval aged eight and four-year-old
orya earlier this month their dad AI
High told global news of his anguish I
have no sense of Vengeance Revenge
nothing at all I just want my family
back
on Sunday we saw a new video of reunions
from Saturday's releases school girls
Emily hand and hila rotem shashani
hugging family they and others in
reasonably good physical health despite
the fact that the uh harsh conditions
they have been under and the um
experience of captivity they did not um
require any emergent Medical uh
intervention also released Sunday
four-year-old Israeli American Abigail
Idan an orphan after her parents were
killed by Hamas US President Joe Biden
says he wants the releases to continue
past Monday well that's our goal to keep
this pause going Beyond tomorrow so that
we can continue to see more hostages
come out and now Hamas says it wants to
extend the pause in fighting to to allow
more hostage and prisoner exchanges
Israeli Prime Minister Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu says he is open to the
proposal of extending the temporary
ceasefire but would also be ready to
resume the military operation in Gaza
Toronto woman Judy Weinstein is believed
to be the only Canadian being held by
Hamas her family will be hoping that if
she is not released Monday that Israel
and Hamas will agree to extend the pause
in fighting Colleen Redmond Shannon in
London Redmond thank you once the
temporary truce ends Israel maintains it
will ramp up its bombardment of Gaza and
move ahead with its war against
Hamas today Israel's prime minister
Benjamin Netanyahu met security forces
inside Gaza and said he has three goals
eliminating Hamas returning all hostages
and ensuring Gaza does not become a
threat to Israel again he also said
Israel will continue until the end until
Victory as hostages get out of Gaza more
critical Aid is making its way in US
President Joe Biden said today that Aid
is surging with approximately 200 trucks
moving into Gaza each day since the
brief pause began and the United Nations
says 129,000 lers of fuel made it into
Gaza today as David Aken reports for Aid
workers inside the Palestinian territory
the looming deadline only compounds the
urgency to deliver critical Aid to those
who need it most
a pause in the conflict and a rush to
deliver humanitarian
Aid outside his partially destroyed home
in southern Gaza Ibraham Canin says
there is no electricity no water and
there are shortages of all basic human
needs his city has a population of
200,000 about the same size as Regina
there still are tremendous shortages in
terms of food clean water um and
medicines in the North in G as a city
this Drone footage was taken during the
humanitarian pause this is where half a
million people live the amount of
Devastation and destruction you can't
really it's like putting a bandaid on a
a gaping wound you know we we are doing
the best that we can Aid agencies and
the UN are doing the best that they can
to um triage and respond the Israel
military has focused its heaviest
attacks here because it says there are
hundreds of kilometers of tunnels
underneath this Rebel used by Hamas to
attack Israel Palestinian Health
officials say the bombardment has killed
more than 14,000 though that number has
not been confirmed by independent
agencies this video obtained by the
independent Reuters news agency shows
alifa Hospital in Gaza City which came
under attack by Israeli forces who
believed Hamas militants were using it
to hide weapons and conduct operations
about 100 patients and healthcare
workers were left at the the hospital a
World Health Organization spokesperson
said the agency was working to evacuate
more before the truce
ends in the very northeast corner of
Gaza in the city of bit hanon residents
use the truce to inspect the ruins of
their homes searching for clothes or any
other belongings among the rubble in
terms of the tremendous amount of need
it's just um four days is nowhere near
enough to really make a dent in in
what's needed
back in southern Gaza as he boils water
to make some
tea Abraham Canin says he asked God that
people's lives would resume and go back
to safety peace and prosperity David
Aken Global
News despite the fragile PA in Gaza
there was more violence in the West Bank
overnight Israeli troops killed five
Palestinians after conducting a raid in
Janine and clashed with a local armed
group they were searching for someone
involved in a lethal ambush in August
along with 20 other suspects Palestinian
Health officials say three others were
also killed in separate incidents across
the territory since October 7th violence
has surged in the West Bank with around
200 Palestinians and four Israelis
killed in si Leon tensions are running
high in the West African country's
capital after armed men attacked a milit
Barracks gunfire could be heard in the
distance the streets empty during the
incident the government says Renegade
soldiers tried to break into an Armory
but were repelled they say most of the
group's leaders are now detained but
officials also say some prisoners
escaped when as salant attacked prisons
in the outskirts a nationwide curfew is
now in effect some new concerns over
Pope francis's Health after he revealed
he was was suffering from lung
inflammation in a televised address the
pope apologized for being unable to give
his usual midday message in St Peter
Square it was delivered instead by an
aid the pontiff recently had the flu
forcing him to cancel some events he
went to hospital on Saturday for a lung
scan but he's still set to visit the UN
climate conference in Dubai on
Friday a shooting in Winnipeg has left
three people dead and two others
critically injured police say they were
called to the scene early this morning
on reports of multiple injured people
Global's Catherine Dorian is following
the story
Katherine Colleen police have been here
on scene for most of the day here on
this street in downtown Winnipeg earlier
this morning officers found five people
who had been shot three of them have
died an adult male and an adult female
were pronounced deceased at the scene
three additional victims were located
and trans ported to hospital in critical
condition one adult male transported to
hospital has since succumbed to his
injuries a man and woman remain in
hospital in critical condition police
say the victim's identities are still
being confirmed and they don't know yet
what the relationships between any of
them may have been police also wouldn't
confirm which building the shooting
happened in but have several residences
taped off as they investigate due to the
complexity of the investigation
forensics will be on this scene for an
extended period police have not reported
any arrests and are asking the public to
come forward with any information they
may have anyone who witnessed anything
suspicious in the area or anyone with
video surveillance is asked to contact
the homicide unit or Crim Stoppers we're
certainly very sadden to provide this
information today where we have uh
multiple lives lost but we're certainly
committed to uh determining exactly what
took place and we'll provide those
details again as the investigation
unfolds police say this investigation
could carry on for weeks or possibly
even longer we did ask if the shooter
could be among the dead or injured they
haven't ruled it out but they say it is
too early to confirm back to you Colleen
Katherine Dorian in Winnipeg thanks
Katherine in Ontario four teenagers and
42-year-old woman were killed in a
collision involving two vehicles it
happened at around 11:00 Saturday night
in the town of Huntsville about 3 hours
north of Toronto the 14s between the
ages of 15 and 17 were pronounced dead
at the scene the woman was pronounced
dead in
hospital Alberta Premier Daniel Smith
says her government will invoke its
controversial sovereignty ACT tomorrow
over the federal government's proposed
clean electricity regulations it'll be
the first time the ACT will be put into
action nearly a year after it was
introduced and as Heather urex West
reports other provinces are keeping a
close eye on how it plays out motion is
carried and so order almost an entire
year old Alberta's sovereignty Act is
gearing up for its first test I have to
tell you I don't want to do this I I I I
really did from the very first
conversation I had with Justin Trudeau
say I wanted to work with him on this on
her weekly chorus radio call-in show
Saturday Premier Daniel Smith confirmed
the sovereignty act will be used this
week to combat ottawa's proposed clean
electricity regulations designed to get
provincial power grids to Net Zero by
2035 we will not put our our our
operators at risk of going to jail if
they do not achieve the targets that
have been set which we believe are
unachievable if Premier Smith wants to
be seen to be doing everything in her
power to stop the federal government um
this certainly speaks to that Danielle
Smith the idea of Alberta opting out of
federal legislation helped Propel
Danielle Smith to Victory as leader of
the province's governing United
conservative party
though the controversial legislation has
been less popular with albertans overall
she needed to convince the Alberta
electorate that she wasn't going to try
to pull Alberta out of Canada instead
the ACT allows Alberta's legislature to
take action against a federal law deemed
unconstitutional or otherwise harmful to
Alberta cabinet could order uh the
federal law to be suspended or put other
Provisions in place in place of the
federal law except in this case there is
no federal law yet the proposed
electricity regulations are only a draft
and Alberta's right to Simply block it
once passed hasn't yet been tested by
the courts we're talking here about
federal regulations that aren't in
forced yet we're talking about a
resolution well we don't know what it
says under an act that's qu frankly
legally dubious so legally I would
characterize this as Shadow Boxing with
magic gloves with the rest of the
country watching closely Alberta's
premere appears ready to ring the bell
for round one Heather urix West Global
News
Calgary coming up OIC Alternatives how a
shortage of the diabetes and obesity
treatment is forcing some diabetics to
use less reliable
medications and the growing calls to rid
a Japanese island of foreign
military
Public Health Canada says one person has
died following a salmonella outbreak
linked to malacha and Ruby brand
cantaloupes there are 63 confirmed cases
linked to the outbreak across five
provinces 17 people have been
hospitalized the health agency issued
recalls for the fruit earlier this month
the recall has now been expanded to
include some pre-cut pineapples honeydew
melons and watermelons processed
alongside the malach and ruik
cantaloupes
some people living with diabetes say
they're being forced to switch their
medication because of a drug shortage
OIC is approved for the treatment of
type 2 diabetes but it's also prescribed
off label for weight loss Heidi petk
reports on where that leaves Canadians
who can't fill their
prescriptions when type 2 diabetic
George yusf went to his Pharmacy to
renew his monthly OIC prescription he
says the pharmacist said they didn't
have enough and wouldn't for months so I
just I was just really taken a back I
figured I'd be out for a month or
something but not 5 months his doctor
has recommended switching medications
I'll need a ramp up period for the new
drug and I'll have to do blood work to
make sure it's not negatively or I don't
have side effects from it and Yousef is
not alone the only thing that they had
left was four pens the shortage of oic's
1 milligram injection pen has others
considering their options they actually
order the pens um every day daily and
they only get four pens a month and then
that set off red flags for me and I went
what OIC manufacturer says increased
worldwide demand is the problem as the
drug makes headlines in other countries
as a quick fix to shed a few pounds the
company says supply issues could persist
into early next year in a statement Nova
Nordisk tells Global News its
manufacturing is quote operating 2 24
hours a day 7 days a week to address
patient needs what we've heard from
pharmacists is that they're estimating
anywhere from 25 to 50% of prescriptions
that they're filling are being used for
weight loss rather than for diabetes
pharmacists can prioritize prescriptions
based on medical need but it's not
always straightforward because there's
so much overlap between people who have
uh obesity and people who have diabetes
one diabetes doctor says patients can
switch to Alternatives but not all of
those are covered by provincial drug
plans this is a good opportunity for
provincial formularies to be expanded uh
to cover the at least one or two other
medications within the same class as
well I'm lucky enough that I have a
doctor to call as Yousef wonders if the
next medication will work as well for
him as the one he can't get Heidi pic
Global News
Halifax I had the struggle to get a US
military base used by Canada off the
Japanese island of
okanawa in the United Nations
Declaration on the rights of indigenous
peoples isn't just an issue within our
borders indigenous rights are in the
spotlight on one Japanese island home to
a US military base used by Canada a base
that's been a source of conflict and
controversy for decades ncha recently
traveled to okanawa and spoke with
locals about what they want
changed just an hour flight east of
Taiwan the location of the Japanese
island of Okinawa is a critical part of
any us military response if China were
to attack
Taiwan but American bases occupy around
8% of the main island causing
indignation among locals like chobin
zukan an anti-war advocate and a former
member of the Japanese House of
Representatives before the World War II
1945 uh there was no military bases in
Okinawa so I would like to see uh
Okinawa without military bases zukan
says the names of his
relatives including his grandfather are
listed here at peace Memorial Park it
honors the lives of those who died in
the Battle of Okinawa and there are rows
upon rows of those names including of
nearly
150,000 Okinawan civilians almost a
third of the Island's indigenous
population those four they don't have to
die they don't have to die it was was
the last major battle of World War II
and one of the bloodiest fought between
us Allied troops including from Canada
and Japanese forces but I
feel how many people died zukan says
what complicates the fight to reduce
military presence on the island is that
Japan doesn't officially recognize
indigenous ryukyuans like he and
activist shako oyakawa we don't have any
um recognition from the government so
that's makes it really hard for us to um
talk about our human rights the central
government argues their Japanese
citizens not indigenous peoples oyakawa
says there's little justification for
that claim she believes there strong
strategic motivation National Security
which Japan's recognition of Okinawan
indigenous rights could put at risk we
want our peaceful Island back this
University economics professor also in
indigenous says the presence of military
bases actually makes the island a Target
I want Canada uh not to invade our
rights they say Canada whose military
regularly uses these bases needs to be
part of a dialogue about the impact on
locals he points to chemical
contamination noise pollution and crimes
committed by US servicemen our message
is dialogue is the most important uh for
peace especially as countries including
Canada commit to the United Nations
Declaration on the rights of indigenous
people around the world he says Japan
needs to rethink both its National
Security and its National History Nara
Global
News next after 119 years Santa still
brings it to kick off the holiday
[Music]
season with just under one month to go
until Christmas Day Santa Claus made an
early appearance in
Toronto hi Hi how are you hey we're back
there he is marching bands performers
and of course the Jolly Old elf himself
we're in the festive spirit for
Toronto's
119th annual Santa Claus Parade it's one
of many Santa Claus parades taking place
across the country today and over the
coming weeks often thought of as the
official start of the holiday
season and that is global national for
this Sunday night I'm calling chrisy
Santa also managed to make his way to
Calgary today dog owners brought their
furry friends out for a photo walk with
the big guy all proceeds will go to
forever homes rescue a charity which
helps find new homes for abandoned and
abused dogs thanks for watching Donna
will be back tomorrow have a great
night
[Music]